sylvie menesson son mari dominique et
leurs deux filles
il a fallu 19 ans pour qu'il soit
reconnu comme famille par l'état
français
car les enfants sont issus d'une
gestation pour autrui à l'étranger
alain comont pas faire d'enfant alors
papa maman et je maintiens j'étais gêné
le combat de la famille nourrit le débat
français sur la gpa depuis les années
2000 à cause d'une malformation sylvie
même sens n'a pas d'utérus
elle et son mari décide alors d'avoir
recours à une mère porteuse aux états
unis où la pratique est légale en
octobre 2000 les jumelles sont nées
c'est ma femme qui a coupé le cordon
ombilical et qui a pris les enfants
contre elle en france dominique et
sylvie men's on se bat pour être
reconnus comme les parents et pour
obtenir la nationalité française pour
leurs enfants
en 2007 c'est chose faite
mais cette décision est annulée par la
cour de cassation l'année suivante
je suis écoeuré qu'ils haussent faire du
mal à mes enfants mes enfants c'est une
famille c'est détruire une famille qui
sont en train de faire je suis écoeuré
vraiment en 2010 retour au tribunal et
victoire en demi-teinte la filiation est
approuvée en revanche pas d'inscription
l état civil pour les jumelles chose
essentielle reste à faire inscrire les
jumelles dont le livret de famille prix
mordelles pour obtenir passeport
affiliation à la sécurité sociale à la
caisse d'allocations familiales entre
autres puis nouveau en guerre depuis
hier chez q combien d'années je reste
tranquille
à quoi ça sert le couple devient un
emblème du combat pour la reconnaissance
des enfants menée de gpa cette
reconnaissance la france l'a envisagé en
2008 rejeté en 2009 à nouveau débattue
en 2010 sans l'adopter en 2014
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
s'en mêle elle condamne la france pour
son refus de reconnaître la parentalité
vraiment contente pour nos enfants que
qu'enfin leurs droits soient reconnus
dans la foulée au plan national la
reculèrent taubira entre en vigueur ce
texte est spécifique les enfants mais de
gpa à l'étranger peuvent obtenir la
nationalité française
leymen son compte relancer une procédure
il n'existe rien qui dit que nous sommes
leurs parents ce sont des fantômes à
n'existe pas pour la république
française nulle part il leur aura fallu
encore quatre ans pour atteindre leur
but
en octobre 2019 la justice reconnaît non
seulement la filiation du couple mes
leçons et plus encore l'acte de
naissance des enfants nés en californie
sera retranscrit en droit français
[Musique]